thousands of protesters in dozens of
cities across russia have taken to the
streets holding up signs and chanting no
to war
russian police have already detained
thousands of people and the government
has been accused of attempting to squash
opposition to moscow's invasion of
ukraine
so how are russians mobilizing in an
increasingly authoritarian environment
and what are the consequences of
speaking up against putin's war joining
us to discuss this is leonid drapkin he
is coordinator of ovd info an
independent human rights media project
that helps the victims of political
persecution in russia thank you so much
for joining us on upfront leonid uh your
organization ovd info has documented
russian police officers beating and
kicking anti-war demonstrators slamming
a man's head on the roof of a car and
even allegedly using a stun gun on the
director of a local red cross branch can
you talk to us about the situation on
the ground and what abuses
you've seen in recent days
so the thing is that our government
unfortunately violates human rights
and people who just
go on the streets uh they are getting
detained and uh well these detentions
itself is a big violation of human
rights and uh i mean we are we're mad
about this and this is not what we like
and in addition to this
they do it in a very brutal way
and we see that the process of detection
itself
is very
brutal and sometimes police kicks
protesters sometimes they use special
special
things to to elector things just to make
them go to a police bus and then when
they are got to a police station
police use violence both uh
psychological and physical in order to
make protesters to
uh
to write uh
the things that they want police want in
their protocols of the detention so that
to make a court
in future to
uh to
place a right decision that police wants
and to find these protesters or to give
them arrests
you talk about arrests and detentions
that's a very important uh subject
between february 24th and february 27th
russian police arrested nearly 6 000
people can you tell us what happens when
a protester is detained and what they
have to go through what consequences
they face
uh the thing is is that this number
increases uh in uh just every every hour
and since russia is a very big country
and we have a lot of time zones and
people go on the streets in
all the cities of russia we see the
tensions like every hour and i can say
that i just got a new information that
as of now
it is not six but seven thousand people
who were detained over the last uh seven
days and it's not about uh one
particular day or one particular uh city
this is very widespread detentions in
many cities of russians of russia over
100 cities we know that there were
detentions over the last week
and yeah after being detained a lot of
people got arrests i i can say roughly
roughly it's five to ten percent of
those who were detained they got
arrested for uh several days for up to
15 days
and uh yeah like i mean those who were
protesting uh a week ago when russia
invaded to ukraine there
they can now be
in a jail and
what are they
charged with right when you go from the
detention to the formal arrest
what are they saying the protester or
the person did
the thing is that
russian
legislation is very repressive and
according to russian law in order to
to hold the rally you need to agree on
it with the municipal municipal power
you need to get a permission from our
authorities
and
you need to send a special well requests
and in most cases
uh of course our
authorities do not accept these requests
they prohibit this public rallies
and if you go on the street without this
permission it means that you violate you
you violate a special law uh when which
states that you are not allowed to take
part in public rally and this is the
reason and according to this law you can
get a fine if you violate it for the
first time and but if you violate it for
the second time you got not only fine
but also arrest for up to 15 or even 30
days in some cases a 60 year old
protester her name was tatiana told ovd
info that these anti-war protests were
the first she had attended since the
dissolution of the soviet union back in
1991.
she said it's scary of course but you
have to go out because people are dying
she said if we don't go out now how will
we look our children in the eyes later
why are these protests so significant in
this moment in time
uh i think that uh
so what we see now
it's like uh the most important uh event
in russian
history since the fall of soviet union i
guess and maybe even in more years and
the thing is that people are now dying
every day in ukraine and nobody knows
how many people died it's it's
definitely thousands of people
but nobody knows how many exactly and
so we need to well people things
think who go to protest who
publish some posts against the war they
they just try to stop it i mean nobody
really cares who will win the war
because there is no winner in any war
and in this war particularly because
like our nations are quite so we have
mutual history with ukraine and now it's
like we are killing each other this is
just insane and everyone thinks that
they should do something in order to
prevent uh further killings but um is
there something different though uh
leona is there something different about
this
uh moment though i mean there are people
who didn't protest last year there are
people who didn't protest 10 years ago
uh
is are things changing is the tide
turning right now
yeah the thing
you're right uh there are a lot of new
people who are coming on the streets who
is like the first
first rally in their life because
this topic
really
touches everyone because it's not about
really your political views but
many russians have relatives and friends
in ukraine and this is just uh a
personal personal pain that that is
going on that's why a lot of people want
to go on the street internet regulators
in russia have slowed down access to
twitter and facebook even more so than
before
both of which are used to disseminate to
the world what's actually happening
inside of russia
journalists and anti-war activists have
been detained and human rights watch has
said quote
the government is silencing all those
who speak out against the war with
ukraine uh how is the information war
playing out
so i think that informational war is
like the
crucial one because and
i can say because
government puts so many efforts to slow
down
internet to so today
many so like i mean one hour ago another
media was closed down in russia and uh
the
the most famous uh tv channel uh
independent tv channel was also closed
down and radio is closes down and i mean
government spends a lot of effort i mean
maybe comparable to what they they have
comparable to efforts they spend on the
war itself just to shut everyone down
because like it's 21st century and the
information plays a lot of role and so i
mean our organization know it's very
well because like our motto is
information protects and we believe that
the more we disseminate information the
more people are protected and the
government also understand this uh this
and they do they do their best uh to
shut everyone down
but uh yeah i mean i mean your
organization in particular has come
under a certain kind of scrutiny from
the government in september of last year
the russian justice ministry added your
organization obd info to its list of
foreign agents
uh what does that classification mean
for organizations like yours and how do
you respond to this type of attack
uh so the thing is that in russia yes
there is a list of foreign engines which
means uh your enemy of a state
and uh this make you make every
organization that is in this list to
mark their pages so that every reader
of uh our resources know that we are
enemies of a state and this is not uh
this is mainly about uh
psychological attack on readers and
users of internet uh rather than uh
there is a direct legal consequences
however uh many organizations are closed
down because not labeling their pages or
facebook posts uh with this special mark
which 24 words that you need to put
in
before before the text you want to post
on facebook and if you don't post it you
can be closed down and many people many
organizations are now being liquidated
because of violating of this law and uh
yeah our organization however so
uh we also in the in december of 2021
our website was also blocked in russia
and uh yeah i mean we are trying to do
our best uh i think that we use a lot of
our social networks
and we have a lot of connection with our
beneficiaries with people who we help
too because like we have a 24 hour by
seven hotline uh so that everyone who
are detained can call us and tell that's
going on
what's going on with them and so we have
a really good connection with the people
who we work for
that's why it makes us
more stable
and more resilient however of course we
are also in a danger as any other human
rights organization in russia looking
ahead do you feel like this moment could
be a turning point uh could it be a game
changer for dissent movements in russia
uh this is uh definitely a focal point
and we
well
game will be changed but
uh the question is in what direction
uh and uh russia now
are moving to
become the second north korea
and uh
it can be a successful movement but if
we if russian society refugees society
uh will show that they are not agree and
if this
uh if this will be successful movement
enough
then it will be a
turning point to a way better life than
like it was i mean
now many decisions are now going on and
uh
well russia will never be the same
definitely uh and unfortunately the more
probable probably it gonna be worse but
i think
it can also be
a bottom that we can just jump from
leonard dropkin thank you so much for
joining me on upfront
thank you thank you very much